on
[Musique]
ne peut pas réécrire l'histoire a
posteriori ou alors évidemment on
s'érige en juge ou en procurèrent ce que
non je comprends d'ailleurs que c'est
l'intention du sénat et vous aurez
on n'agit pas comme ça entre amis et
avec des alliés c'est un raisonnement à
très courte vue parce qu'il pense avoir
gagné sur un contrat mais ils ont
beaucoup perdu sur le long terme sur la
confiance
absolue des barbes la gare du nord à
paris devait tripler sa superficie 17
2024 pour les jo mais finalement la sncf
a annoncé hier hier soir qu'elle jeter
les ponts et notez d'ailleurs que c'est
jean baptiste djebbari le ministre des
transports qui sera l'invitée un chiffre
ce matin 12 milles 7 c'est un projet qui
a glissé vers un milliard et demi donc
qu'ils ont triplé en coups et qui en
plus s'est vue décalé de deux à trois
ans en calendrier c'est quand même la
chronique d'un projet qui s'est mal
déroulée sur le plan technique qui pour
mettre un terme à la vente de crack à
ciel ouvert à paris la maire de paris et
l'état se renvoient la balle c'est à la
nuit tombée qu'anne hidalgo harry
finalement près des jardins d'eole les
changes démarre avec des toxicomanes
[Musique]
parfois attaquer pour 10
c'est totalement surréaliste on voit des
camions qui ont débarqué le matin même
avant sa visite ce sont les riverains
qui ont monté tout ça et puis un
nettoyage à fond de ce fameux pont sur
lequel se trouvent normalement les
drogués la réponse de du préfet de
police elle est de dire
il faut accepter pour un temps ici dans
trois mois ailleurs ces situations de
deal à ciel ouvert je ne l'acceptent pas
prêt jean castex c'est au tour
d'emmanuel macron le président de la
république a vu le qr code correspondant
à son passé ni terre publiées sur les
réseaux sociaux les vannes des finances
publiques sont ouvertes classique pour
une dernière année de quinquennat depuis
le début du mois plus de 5 milliards
d'euros de dépenses annoncées 1,5
milliard d'euros à marseille 600
millions pour les agriculteurs 500
millions pour les policiers 300 millions
pour les harkis 580 millions pour le
shaq énergie 50 millions pour la pêche
aujourd'hui on est dans un mois qu'il en
coûte électorale qui va se faire sur le
dos des français et c'est pour ça que
nous demandons aux prises en afrique et
au gouvernement est bien de maîtriser
les dépenses et d'arrêter de cramer la
caisse nous avons dépensé l'argent
public à bon escient pour vous protéger
pour protéger l'emploi pour protéger des
compétences pour protéger des
entreprises des dépenses qui ne sont pas
dans le budget ce sont des annonces qui
n'existe pas c'est juste de la promesse
électorale mais ça n'a aucune réalité
budgétaire puisque la seule chose qui
compte c'est ce qui est dans le budget
c'est bien si vous avez un crédit qui
est ouvert ou paris une potentielle que
nature et l'eczéma
non seulement
j'y passe comme ça
allez vous voulez d'autres
surtout c'est un débat qui doit être
plus fort avec mélenchon anticipe
vous le dire mais antidote de rien du
tout non mais ça c'est son opinion non
mais j'ai appelé les français démontre
l'engagement avait déjà donné mais c'est
quoi tes éléments non je vous mettrai
dans les landes les pourtours ont plus
parlé des excuses et le défi relevé le
défi d'un débat public sur la question
qui les autres chaînes et s'est dit matt
s gêner mois ils vont du jeu dans le
set à l'arrêt de paris match demain eric
zemmour et sa très proche conseillère
une enquête une enquête sur une femme
sarah knafo éminence grise du
journaliste polémiste aujourd'hui
presque candidat demain personne ne doit
donner de leçons sur ce terrain si vous
passez sur
lui l'ont sorti de quoi elle vous a dit
alors quand il se déclarera candidat
j'ai cru comprendre elle me l'a laissé
entendre de manière subtile à nouveau mi
novembre